[Music]
leggo was born back in 1932 in Denmark
and managed to capture the attention of
the entire world with the motto of only
the best is good enough Lego created one
of the most famous toys in the entire
world did you know that you can make 915
million different things from just six
Lego bricks imagine what kind of
creations you can do with thousands of
them keep up to date with our videos by
clicking the red subscribe button give
this video a thumbs up if you're a lego
fan today we're discussing 10 most
amazing LEGO creations ever Lego tower
did you know that the tallest Lego tower
is made from five hundred and fifty
thousand bricks and it's one hundred and
fourteen feet and 11 inches tall this
impressive Tower made the Guinness world
record as the tallest structure built
with interlocking plastic bricks and we
all know that by those plastic bricks
they actually mean more than half a
million LEGO pieces pretty impressive
right this tower was built in 2015 in
Milan but you can find many towers like
these around the world that are
competing for their spot in the world
record book this tower out built a
similar Lego tower in Hungary which was
114 feet and point 50 inches tall but
the beauty of the tower in Milan is that
for every point four inches the team
donated seven euros to a project that
protects and develops urban oasis with a
crowd of 50,000 spectators
it's took 18,000 builders 5 days to put
this impressive structure together but
the work definitely paid off the very
final brick was put on by the Italian TV
personality Alejandro Catalan the best
part about competing for the tallest
Lego structures is that you can always
just add a few more pieces to keep your
world record title Lego dinosaur there
are no limits to LEGO creations and it's
true what they say you can build
anything you set your mind to take for
example this dinosaur that looks like it
might as well be part of an actual
museum this t-rex was part of the global
touring exhibitions called the art of
the brick it was designed by Nathan
Sawaya who got his first Lego set when
he was 5 years old he was since then
inspired to create some of the most
amazing structures one of his greatest
creations is this t-rex dinosaur which
is about 19 feet tall and made from
80,000 Lego bricks Nathan said that this
work boosts his creativity and reflects
the artists growth
he had one goal for his exhibition which
originally launched in 2007 the
exhibition features everything from
famous paintings to DC superheroes
Nathan wanted to make his art relatable
to both children and adults but also
take it to the next level and create
artwork no one has ever done before the
exhibition holds 100 objects and 1
million bricks we can't even imagine how
long it took Nathan to make these
structures this dinosaur really looks
like it could be placed in a Natural
History Museum the Loch Ness monster
building an impressive Lego structures
on the ground is one thing but building
them in water is even more fascinating
you've heard of the Loch Ness monster
right it's a legend of a giant sea
creature that lives in the Scottish lake
called Loch Ness this Green Monster has
never been really seen but the legend
remains check out this incredible Loch
Ness monster made entirely from Lego
bricks
while the Loch Ness monster might or
might not exist it doesn't mean you
can't use your imagination to bring it
to life in some way you can find this
Loch Ness monster in Disney World
Florida and if you do see it make sure
you take a picture it's amazing you'd be
surprised how huge the lego Loch Ness
monster looks in person its head stands
on 20 feet above the lake and it's
approximately 60 feet long although
we're not sure why you can see this
monster in Disney World Florida hey
since you have the chance you should
totally go see it of course you can also
build your own version of Nessie using
just a few bricks but the question on
our mind is will we ever see the real
Loch Ness monster Lego cars cars are
also a popular thing to make with your
Lego bricks and the best part is you can
make them small or they can be huge like
this car ever wanted to drive a lego car
we're totally jealous of this guy and
his amazing design
this car belongs to the 20 year old Raul
Oh ADA from Romania this yellow car is
the world's first fully functioning cars
made from 500,000 LEGO bricks
it's called the super awesome micro
project everything is made from LEGO
bricks including the engine which runs
on air although its top speed is only
about 18 miles per hour this is one of
the most creative designs we have ever
seen Raoul claims this car was only
possible to be done because of the
internet he met an Australian
entrepreneur Steve Sammartino who helped
him with the project and brought it to
life Steve said that he is teaching
Raoul about business and Raoul is
teaching him about physics he also
explained that the project got funded
with a single tweet although Lego cars
might not be practical or safe this is
one of the most amazing LEGO creations
we have seen we can't wait to see what
Raul builds next lego warship so far
we've mentioned sea creatures towers
cars and dinosaurs what do you think
comes next
Lego proves there is really no limit to
your creativity with this next design
this warship is called Yamato and it's
the biggest Lego ship ever constructed
it's 22 feet long and it took six years
and four months to complete it
absolutely amazing isn't it it's a
tribute to the real Yamato the largest
battleship that ever existed and it was
more than 862 feet long but this mini
Yamato ship was made from 200,000 Lego
bricks and weighed an impressive amount
of 330 pounds pretty good right this
warship had everything you would see in
a normal battle ship including army men
and some impressive weaponry it even has
a lego flag aircraft space planes and
smaller battleships the artist who
designed the ship cleverly used a lego
marketplace to source the lego elements
that were crucial to building the ship
these elements include the Japanese Navy
flag and the Imperial Chris stamps
emblem we wonder how the artist managed
to move this piece anywhere after it was
completed how cool is this we bet this
will give you some inspiration for your
next future Lego project and who knows
it might take you 6 years to complete it
Lego Colosseum another amazing LEGO
creation is the Colosseum and no it's
not the small Colosseum said you can buy
in the store this masterpiece
was built by Ryan McKnight a famous Lego
builder who creates award-winning
sculptures with nothing but Lego bricks
his nickname the brick man is
well-deserved just check out this
incredible sculpture this impressive
Lego Colosseum is made of more than two
hundred thousand bricks this Colosseum
was built for the Australians Nicholson
Museum and Ryan knew it was going to be
a popular sculpture on the Internet and
he was right this sculpture is over
three feet high and almost six feet long
but it wasn't as easy to build as it
looks Ryan claims that the Colosseum is
the most technically challenging thing
he's ever built it turns out building
something oval-shaped it isn't easy even
for a lego structure but Ryan's hard
work paid off because this project is
just as amazing from the outside as it
is on the inside just like in the real
Colosseum the LEGO version misses pieces
to represent the structures ongoing
decay through the years it's layout is
spot-on with gladiators and audience
soldiers and everything you find in a
real Colosseum we're not sure how long
this sculpture took to make but we can
imagine it wasn't an easy project good
job Ryan Lego pizza although it's
definitely not the biggest construction
from this list it doesn't make it any
less fascinating just a warning this
might make you a little bit hungry this
pizza was made by a Japanese lego
creator called tari and it's definitely
one of the most delicious LEGO creations
we have seen check out the detail on
this pizza can you name all the
ingredients on here we see pepperoni
ketchup green peppers and we're in love
with the melted cheese what do you think
the white round things are Mon Sorella
cheese the detail is amazing and we
wonder how long it took him to find the
right pieces to finish this incredible
Lego food collection
tari also created a whole collection of
other food types from junk food bento
boxes to desserts this Lego collection
has your food cravings covered don't
like junk food don't worry you can find
healthy food here too like this awesome
banana or even this highly detailed
broccoli the only bad part about this
collection is you're not really allowed
to eat it do you think tari had many
food cravings while he was making these
tari has some advice for all inspired
Lego builders go beyond what people
usually do with the bricks because
that's what we do
Kennedy Space Center speaking of going
beyond what people usually do with Lego
bricks you should check out this amazing
Kennedy Space Center you wouldn't
believe how many bricks this sculpture
took and how many hours it took the
creators to make this 750,000 bricks and
2500 hours yep you heard that right
2500 hours it's about 104 days and more
than three months can you imagine
building something for three months
straight the masterpiece is pretty much
mind-blowing it includes a six feet and
13 inches tall Space Shuttle and nine
feet Saturn 1b rocket and the eight feet
long Vehicle Assembly Building which was
made out of fifty thousand Lego bricks
how impressive is that although this
space shuttle will never see the actual
space it shows us that you can create
just about anything using Lego bricks
which structure from space do you want
to see next
a UFO we hope this video is making you
inspired but don't worry it's not over
yet and it only gets better we'll give
you a hint
the next Lego construction is an
important historical event that happened
back in 2009 and almost everyone in the
world was watching it what could it be
Obama's inauguration have you guessed it
if you're looking for a highly detailed
Lego creation you've found it it's
Obama's complete inauguration and it's
very impressive this masterpiece can be
found in Legoland in California and we
think they did a really good job check
it out from the parking lot to the crowd
this piece has some of the most amazing
detail we have ever seen it's made from
hundreds of thousands of bricks and we
can't even imagine how long it lasted
for the creators to build it how many
characters can you recognize in the
audience the designers made sure they
did an amazing job with the figurines
and the characters are definitely
recognizable the Vice president-elect o
Biden Michelle Obama Obama's daughters
George W Bush Barbara Bush and more if
you look closer you can even find Oprah
Winfrey in the crowd the figurines are
all faceless which makes the fact that
they're recognized
that much more amazing very impressive
but here's the sad part this creation
was only available for a limited amount
of time back in 2009 but that doesn't
mean there are other masterpieces worthy
of your visit really has no limits all
you need is imagination and a lot of
patience legoland
without a doubt one of the most amazing
LEGO creations that ever existed is the
Legoland a whole theme park built of
Legos with more Lego sculptures inside
yes please it sounds like a dream and
it's actually a reality you can find six
Lego lands out there and they're based
all around the world along with having
Lego rides you can also find amazing
structures like you've never seen before
the Legoland itself consists of more
than 65 million bricks it took eight
hundred and thirty thousand bricks to
build just the exact replicas of some of
the world's tallest buildings which
include Burj Khalifa Shanghai Tower
Makkah
oil clock tower Hotel One World Trade
Center and Taipei 101 very impressive
along with fascinating mega structures
you can also find interactive 3d rides
and 118 feet tall viewpoints that allow
you to see the entire theme park pretty
cool right so what else can you expect
when you visit like a LAN well there are
water parks aquariums and even hotels
and although the hotels aren't made from
Lego bricks on the outside the building
is a replica of a Lego brick made hotel
on the inside you can find themed rooms
and choose from pirate adventure Kingdom
and Lego friend themes what's the best
LEGO creation you've ever made let us
know in the comments below don't forget
to subscribe to our channel and hit the
like button if you love Legos for more
entertaining videos check out the
amazing evolution of iconic children's
toys thanks for watching
[Music]